vingt ans après l'engagement des troupes
françaises en afghanistan une dizaine de
vétérans français blessés en opération
ont choisi de réunir leurs photos
personnelles pour en faire une
exposition il leur en donnait un sens
par l'écrit avec des textes intimes
associés à chaque photographie ce ne
sont pas des photos professionnelles ce
sont des photos réalisées par des
militaires en mission sur le terrain
pris à la volée et tous les cartels tous
les petits textes qui sont en dessous
c'est eux qui vise à chaque auteur de
chaque photo a rédigé son texte aidés
par l'association escal l'exposition
répond à un travail de mémoire elle met
en avant les aspects humains et sublime
le pays pour en souligner la beauté
malgré la brutalité du contexte leur
choix délibéré était de dire
on parle de la beauté de ce pays de ce
qui nous a marqués et ce qui nous reste
20 ans après et bien c'est les paysages
les rencontres la richesse de ces
rencontres les la fraternité d'armes
quand on est rentré en 2001 soul et
aliments toutes les femmes étaient
habillées comme celle qui se trouve à
gauche et puis au cours des années qui
ont suivi cette photo est prise en 2008
donc sept ans après eh bien on commence
à voir des femmes sortir se promener
librement dans la ville sans être
accompagnée n'ai eu beaucoup d'action
fait pour permettre aux femmes de
circuler librement de retourner à
l'école de faire des études d'avoir un
travail une exposition également
libératrice pour les vétérans blessés
qui ont pu se reconstruire grâce à ce
travail c'est un travail de
réhabilitation
des blessés par un projet qu'ils ont
monté et qu'ils ont réalisés par eux
mêmes au total c'est une soixantaine
d'oeuvres qui sont présentés
l'exposition est accessible à tout
public jusqu'au 18 février à l'espace
arnaud beltrame à poissy